Hello and welcome on board.
The most exciting feature of this next-generation A380...
...is our new premium economy cabin.
Let me show you around.
You'll find 56 plush, comfortable seats in a 2-4-2 configuration.
The seats have a generous pitch of up to 40 inches.
So, you get more space.
You will notice luxurious touches...
...such as the anti-stain leather seat covers,...
...headrests that adjust six ways and adjustable calf and leg rests.
The seats also adjust to a cradle position...
...in an 8-inch recline to help you relax.
Other premium features are wooden trim, in arm dining table...
...and even a cocktail table in your seat.
Every seat has ample stowage and connectivity for your convenience.
There's over 4,500 channels on-demand for your entertainment...
...on the 13.3 inch full HD touchscreen TVs.
And of course, our award-winning service completes the Emirates experience.
Fly better in premium economy.